sorry Sarge  but I didn't last hey how's that project  coming really need it end a day today  I'll give him my full attention you've  switched off your computer  what's wrong nothing I'm alright okay  and today buddy  laugh it up fuzzball yes crunchy I know  the transmissions broken Oh Doritos can  I get one these are not the chips you're  looking for no I love not so cheese  they're my favorite these are not the  favourite thing they're looking for  oh my god your breath  damnit yes give in to your hate give in  to your what are you getting dad for his  birthday I think it's weird that he  calls me little princess singing of  getting a humidifier I feel like you  could really benefit from that  what No ah  God Jesus again there's a lot to explain  but it think it's best if you just watch  this